Oh,
good case that illustrates a lot of the
issues that we're going to be talking
about over the course of the course.
Uh,
is the case of Arkansas
versus Ricky rector.
Uh,
this was a case out of a,
and it's in the readings,
uh,
out of,
Conway,
which is in Faulkner County,
Arkansas.
Tragic death here of a police officer,
Bob Martin,
who had come to a rest Ricky rector,
who had shot and killed someone else
just a short time before and had been,
uh,
on the run.
Uh,
but he agreed to come back
to his mother's house.
And Bob Martin was the friend of the
family and he came to arrest him and to
everyone's complete shock and amazement.
Rector walks up behind Martin,
uh,
and shoots him.
But then what he does next,
[inaudible] walk out in the backyard
and put the gun to his own head,
uh,
and give himself basically
a frontal lobotomy.
A lot of people thought
that retro wouldn't live,
but he did.
And so then the question becomes,
what do we do in this case?
Uh,
this is a community that had never
before even had a police officer shot,
let along the police officer killed.
And so there's a tremendous
reaction in the community,
uh,
because Bob Martin had been
a great public servant.
He was loved by people there.
Uh,
and there was a feeling that the death
penalty should be imposed because of this
loss of a law enforcement official.
This case is full of politics from the
start to the very end when Bill Clinton
running for president in 1992 comes back
to preside over the execution of Ricky
rector.
Uh,
right before the New Hampshire primary,
in fact,
Clinton had scheduled the execution
by signing a death warrant,
uh,
so that rector would be executed.
But rector who had been a pretty troubled
person and somewhat troubled mentally
to begin with,
uh,
was even more severely impaired
after he shot himself through the,
uh,
front of his head.
Uh,
and we'll talk a little bit about
how that was looked at in the case.
Uh,
but first I just raised the question,
what do you do if you're the district
attorney there in Faulkner County?
Uh,
the police of course
want the death penalty.
We don't know what the
Martin family wanted,
but we assume the family may
have wanted the death penalty.
Uh,
no question.
The community wants the death penalty,
but we have a man now who is profoundly
damaged as a result of this self
inflicted wound.
Uh,
do we still seek the
death penalty if we do?
What's our purpose?
Is the purpose to show people regardless
of whatever the facts are about Ricky
rector,
is the purpose to show people
that if you come to Conway,
Arkansas and kill one
of our police officers,
you're going to get the death penalty.
Uh,
or is there other considerations that
should take into account the individual
circumstances of rector?
Uh,
would it be possible has happened
in the Jared Lochner case,
the person who shot Gabrielle Giffords,
the congressman and killed a federal
judge as well as a little girl and other
people in that case was ultimately
resolved with a plea disposition where the
families and the community
and everybody agreed.
The best thing in this case is to make
sure that Jerry Lochner is never in the
community again.
Uh,
but not to go through a death penalty
trial and the appeals and so forth that
would go with it.
Well,
that obviously wasn't the
decision that was made,
uh,
in Faulkner County.
Uh,
but it's important to point out to
decisions that the prosecutor had to make
first whether to seek
the death penalty at all.
It's never required to
seek the death poly,
no,
no cases,
a mandatory death penalty case.
And then second,
even after the prosecutor had announced
were seeking the death penalty in this
case,
he would always offer a plea bargain
life imprisonment without any possibility
of parole,
uh,
resolve the case without a trial.
Uh,
and,
and of course,
the different sentence,
uh,
in this case,
both those questions were answered that
the prosecutor was going to go forward
with a prosecution.
It was felt that they
wanted the death pony,
even if Ricky rector
wasn't the same person.
We want the death pony for Ricky rector,
uh,
because of what happened in the community
and maybe for this deterrence purpose
that I talked about.
Uh,
but,
but you can see that that issue
is not just a legal question.
Is he eligible for the death politic?
Uh,
it was certainly his because
he shot a police officer,
uh,
but in killed a police officer,
but also a lot of political questions.
And of course the prosecutors got to
run for reelection and Faulkner County.
So how much does that
factor into the process?
And then of course,
what happened in the case was there's
no question rector committed the crime.
Every one knew that.
So the question becomes,
is he competent?
Is He as a result of
his damage to his brain?
Is he mentally competent,
uh,
to,
stand trial.
Now we have the defense
doctors who saw him,
Dr. Brown,
Dr. Stephens,
a psychologist,
a Mr. Hello.
Dr Heller.
Uh,
as well as his,
um,
uh,
or excuse me,
Heller is his attorney
and the Criswell case,
uh,
the one that had tried before,
and his sister all describe how
Ricky rector is functioning.
And we come out from that with a
diagnosis that he has retrograde Amnesia,
he's damaged his brain damage.
He's got no emotion whatsoever.
You go see him one day and he doesn't
remember having talked to you the last
time you went to see him.
Uh,
his intellectual functioning is
tested 66 later tested at 70.
But basically this is a person,
uh,
who not only is his thinking,
it's sort of a childlike level,
but is acting,
uh,
at a child like level,
very,
uh,
childish in,
in the way he behaves.
Uh,
the state doctors on the other hand,
uh,
Dr Ahmed is the main state doctor.
He says,
rectors lying about his loss of memory.
Uh,
there doesn't have
anything to do with this.
A bullet wound,
uh,
through his,
through his brain.
Uh,
and uh,
he even says it.
By the second trial he had improved.
The state also had a,
another uh,
psychiatrist and two psychologists.
So you can see a lot of
experts in this case,
unusual for a case involving a
poor person to have this many,
uh,
experts too on the defense side and not
unusual for the state to have for a on
its side.
Uh,
but where does that get us?
They decided,
uh,
the state doctors that he was faking it,
and then he was not cooperating,
uh,
in,
answering their questions and that
his lack of emotion and his childlike
behavior,
uh,
they said work life
choices that he had made.
Uh,
so,
uh,
what do we do with these?
These are the same
diagnosis we had before.
The defense experts
come to the conclusion,
manifestly incapable of assisting
his lawyers in any way that he's too
childlike,
too injured,
uh,
to,
damaged,
uh,
to work with.
As lawyers state,
uh,
these doctors decide he could choose.
Again,
they're saying that he's faking it and
all that they're saying if he wants to
cooperate with his lawyers,
he can and therefore there's no
problem going forward with this.
This is what the Arkansas
Supreme Court will later say,
that the evidence was
hopelessly in conflict.
This doctors reach one conclusion,
one diagnosis,
the state doctors,
another diagnosis,
another conclusion.
How does this get resolved?
One person,
one person resolves it.
Uh,
and that's the trial judge.
Of course,
he too is elected by the voters
there and Faulkner County.
Uh,
whether or not that comes into play,
uh,
we don't know,
but we can't help but know that there's
got to be some political pressure,
uh,
there with regard to it.
Let's look at the legal issue that
was presented by rectors case.
Uh,
and,
and what other issues
are presented by his,
his mental health.
Was he competent to stand trial?
Most fundamental question in this case,
and this is what the case is all about
because I said there's no question that
he's guilty of the crime.
Uh,
not much question that a jury and Faulkner
County is going to sentence him to
death.
And he ends up with an all white jury in
a community that has about 10% African
American.
Um,
the standard,
the statute is set out here,
the Arkansas Code,
which provides that a person who
lacks the capacity to understand the
proceedings that is,
understand what's going on,
who the judge is,
the prosecutor,
the jurors,
uh,
and how the proceedings are taking place
or assist his lawyer that is be able to
have conversations with his lawyer,
relate information,
uh,
and that sort of thing.
As a result of a mental disease or defect,
uh,
is not to be tried if
they lack this capacity.
So those are the two
questions we're asking.
Can Rector understand the
proceedings and can he,
uh,
cooperate with his lawyers?
Can he interact with his lawyers in a
way that makes it possible for them to
represent them?
And as I said,
the whole case is going to
be decided on this one issue.
And as I said,
the judge is the person
who's going to decide it.
So the judge decided that he's competent
and then the importance of that finding
by that one trial judge means that when
the case goes to the Arkansas Supreme
Court,
it affirms and it says the
evidence is hopelessly in conflict.
So we defer to the trial judge.
The trial judge was the
person who heard the evidence,
saw the witnesses,
uh,
and unless it's clearly erroneous,
unless it's absolutely clear
to us that he made a mistake,
uh,
with regard to finding of competence,
we're going to defer to his findings.
Every court when the case is later
reviewed in the federal courts,
uh,
those,
findings are going to be
a binding on those courts.
So you see how the power of this one
man or really we see the power of two
people here,
the prosecutor seeking the death penalty,
not plea bargaining in the case,
and then the power of the judge to decide
the legal issue that's going to decide
the whole case.
If rector had been found
not to be competent,
he would have been sent to a mental
institution and he would have stayed there
until either became competent or it was
determined that he just was not going to
ever be competent.
Uh,
but of course here he was found competent,
which meant that the
case moved on to trial.
Let me just mention a couple of other
issues raised by these mental issues.
Often in cases,
one is sanity.
We've all heard of the insanity defense.
Uh,
seldom really used successfully in cases,
particularly by poor people who usually
can't afford the expert witnesses and
often can't get them from the court
in order to even try to prove.
But the difference here,
when we talk about sanity,
we're talking about the person's mental
condition at the time of the crime,
whether or not the
person had the capacity.
Again,
the ability we're talking about to
conform his or her behavior to the
requirements of the law and
appreciate the criminality,
uh,
of what he or she did.
In other words,
the person who shoots someone because
they think they're an enemy soldier who's
the invading the country,
and they have a delusional belief.
They believe this completely.
I mean,
that's sort of your classic example of a,
of an insanity defense.
Don't have that in this
case because of course,
rectors damage to his
brain and his functioning,
uh,
was a result of an injury he inflicted
after he committed the crime.
So no question about his sanity at the
time he shot and killed Bob Martin.
Uh,
mitigation is,
we'll talk about later.
Uh,
is rectors condition a reason
for a sentence less than death?
Uh,
do we take this into account?
We look at the crime,
uh,
the heinousness of the crime
of the loss to the community.
Uh,
but do we also look at rectors condition?
And there's some argument about this,
about,
well,
that wasn't his condition
at the time of the crime,
so we shouldn't consider it.
And the other side,
well,
that is his condition.
Now this is the situation.
This man is in profoundly damaged
as a result of this gunshot wound.
Uh,
and so perhaps this is not a person
who should be sentenced to death.
The Arkansas Supreme Court when
presented with this question and said,
well,
this is a matter for executive clemency.
Of course,
at the time they said that,
uh,
or for the governor to consider
for executive clemency,
Chris,
at the time,
they considered that
they didn't know that,
uh,
clemency would come up at a time when
the governor was running for president of
the United States and his law and
order Bona Fides would be the most,
one of the most important
issues in the case,
as someone said,
for Ricky rector.
That timing was very bad indeed.
Uh,
and then finally at the end of the case,
the question came up whether rector
was competent to be executed.
As I mentioned just a little earlier,
uh,
whether or not he understood
why he was being executed.
Uh,
so those are,
uh,
this case gives you a sense again of
the way in which these issues come up in
cases.
Retros case was not a celebrated
case when it first came up in Conway,
Arkansas,
but of course it became a fairly well
known case at the very end because the
role it played in Bill Clinton's
campaign for President United States.
Uh,
and it certainly was seen by a lot of
people as protecting Clinton from any
attack that he was soft on crime,
uh,
that he would not be like the previous
Democratic nominee Michael to caucus,
uh,
who had been opposed to the death penalty.
Uh,
and that cost him a fairly dearly with
the ads that were run against him when he
ran for president.
Well,
uh,
let's go from that just to quickly talk
about how these cases make their way
through the system.
Uh,
obviously any criminal case is going
to start with a crime being committed,
uh,
and then an investigation which can
last for as long as a few seconds.
If the offender is a apprehended right
there on the scene or can last for
months,
years,
however long it takes for law enforcement
and the prosecutors to decide who it
is that committed the crime.
Um,
once we know who committed the crime,
then there's going to be an arrest.
Uh,
again,
that may be very soon.
Or you may have somebody who has fled
the country or fled the jurisdiction.
So that may take some period of time.
Here's where we want to get into
the legal proceedings to take place.
Those things you probably
a pretty familiar with.
When you're arrested,
you're entitled to a
first appearance hearing.
In other words,
within a day or two of being arrested,
a person should be brought
before a judicial officer,
a judge,
or a magistrate.
Uh,
and the question here,
that's critically important.
Do you get a lawyer at that point?
Because if you're accused of any crime,
you want a lawyer at this point
because if you're on a minor crime,
you're hoping to get out on bail a so
you can go back to work so you can keep
your home,
uh,
carry on your life,
in hope that maybe you won't
ever go to prison on this case.
If you're in a serious case and death
point in case you want your while you're
out investigating the
case right from the start.
Diego Martin who was facing
the death plenty in del Rio,
Texas,
gets arrested,
asked for a lawyer eight months.
He goes for eight months facing
the death penalty with no lawyer.
And you can imagine the damage that
does to his case in terms of there's no
investigation.
He's not able to talk to
a lawyer about his case.
What's going on.
Uh,
he basically just sits
in jail for eight months.
The prosecution is building its case,
uh,
and he is not,
at any rate at this first hearing of
judge will usually tell the defendant what
his or her rights are.
Uh,
set bail.
Most capital cases,
no bail is set in capital cases,
but in other cases,
the court will set bail or uh,
in some cases release people on
their personal promise to come back.
That is their personal Rick cognizance.
A short time after that
in most jurisdictions.
And this is what Chris,
we're generalizing here across all states.
And so some of these
things are not as true,
maybe one place to another,
but most places within
a short time after that,
uh,
the defendant has a preliminary hearing,
is represented by client,
by,
by a lawyer.
Uh,
of course,
if you don't have a lawyer,
like in the case I mentioned,
uh,
for eight months,
you're probably not going
to have preliminary hearing
because no lawyer is going
to request a preliminary hearing,
uh,
for you.
Uh,
but at that hearing,
uh,
the court determines,
the judge determines a,
whether there's probable cause that is,
whether it's probable that the
person committed the crime,
uh,
and if so,
the person can continue to be
held either on bail or in prison.
Uh,
most states still have grand juries,
not all in some states,
the prosecution's can just simply,
prosecutors,
excuse me,
can just
file an accusation which
sets out the charges.
Uh,
but in a lot of states,
the cases presented to a grand jury,
uh,
it considers the evidence and
then returned an indictment.
And the indictment is the formal charge.
The fact that somebody has been indicted
does not mean they committed a crime.
It just means they're
formally charged with a crime.
Uh,
original purpose of the grand jury or
one of its purposes had been that if you
were accused of something you didn't
do a and the grand jury did not indict,
you wouldn't go through the,
uh,
public embarrassment of being accused.
Because today,
uh,
that's really not the case.
Grand Juries are used to gather evidence
and investigate cases and generally
everybody knows who's
being investigated by,
by the grand jury,
at least in,
in cases of any prominence.
Once a person's indicted by the grand
jury or they're brought before the court
for Arraignment,
this is the proceeding where the person
enters a plea of not guilty a or in some
cases,
this will be where the cases
resolved with a guilty plea.
Certainly in a lot of non capital cases,
a lot of people,
a lot of poor people accused of crimes
will meet their lawyer for the first time
at arraignment,
will plead guilty and be sentenced all
within about a 15 minute time period.
Uh,
capital cases,
generally a not guilty plea is going
to be entered because nobody's going to
plead guilty or unless
less they want the death.
Probably most people are going
to plead not guilty here.
Uh,
and then we go to pretrial hearings,
which can be on all the issues,
uh,
that,
maybe litigated pretrial,
whether to change the venue in the case.
Should we move it to another
place where there's not a,
the kind of knowledge of the case
that there was in the rector case.
Uh,
is there,
uh,
suppression of evidence?
Uh,
the competency issue,
uh,
in the retro case is a good example.
This issue was not an issue.
Tried to a jury.
This was an issue that was decided in
a pretrial hearing before the judge.
Uh,
there may be other issues like,
uh,
motions to suppress identification
because it was suggestive or some other,
uh,
motion to suppress the
confession because the person,
uh,
it was not a voluntary confession or
there was a violation of Miranda versus
Arizona.
Basically any issue that's a legal
issue that needs to be resolved,
uh,
can be litigated before that is uh,
you know,
motion can be filed and the
parties can argue about it,
present evidence on and the
judge decides it before trial,
before we get to the issue
of guilt or innocence.
Sometimes there'll be issues about what
evidence is going to be admitted or not.
And the judge will rule
upon that prior to trial.
Once that happens,
uh,
we moved to,
this process,
the trial,
uh,
this is a where the trial
is going to take place.
This is where the accused is entitled
to a lawyer under the Supreme Court's
decision.
And Gideon versus Wainwright.
Uh,
and in depth pony cases,
this will be a bifurcated trial.
That is two trials,
one trial and guilt,
one trial on penalty,
uh,
after assuming the person is convicted,
found guilty in some states,
like Alabama is a good example.
There's an intermediate court of
appeals that is as the Alabama Court of
criminal appeals.
And then above it,
the Alabama Supreme Court,
all these cases go first to the Alabama
Court of criminal appeals and decides
the case.
And then a person can
petition the Supreme Court,
uh,
to review the case,
but it's not required to.
Most states the cases bypass
the intermediate court.
They go straight from the trial
court to the state Supreme Court.
Texas,
for example,
has a whole level of
intermediate appellate courts,
but the death pawn in
cases don't go there.
They go straight from the trial court to
the Texas Court of criminal appeals or
in Georgia from the trial court
to the Georgia Supreme Court.
And then that state court
makes a decision of whether,
uh,
reviews the trial,
the briefs that are filed to see was
there any legal error made at the trial,
either in those pretrial motions that we
just talked about or admitting evidence
during the trial jury
instructions that were given,
anything that may have been
discussed or a decided not discussed,
but decided,
uh,
at the trial court level,
the State Supreme Court May Review,
a party can ask the United States
Supreme Court to review it by filing a
petition in the Supreme
Court seeking review.
Almost always,
except in the rare case
that's going to be denied a.
So this is what we call direct
appeal directly from the trial court,
uh,
up through the state Supreme Court.
Now,
once that process is ended,
person theoretically is eligible to be
executed because they've had their trial
and they've had their appeal.
Uh,
but all states provide
some kind of collateral,
what we call collateral,
a attack on the conviction
or post conviction review.
Uh,
and here the person can go back to
the trial court and file a petition or
emotion saying my death
sins or my conviction was
obtained in violation of the
constitution,
the laws of the United States
and this particular state.
But one thing,
the person cannot raise any issue here
that could have been raised at trial or
in the state supreme court.
So what does that leave?
If you've already raised these issues
before trial or during trial and you've
raised them in the state Supreme Court,
what's left?
Uh,
generally one issue,
uh,
heard here is a question of
ineffective assistance of counsel.
Obviously the lawyer can't be claiming
to be ineffective while representing
someone,
the lawyers hopefully providing and
thinks he or she is providing effective
representation.
So that question can be decided here.
Uh,
suppression of exculpatory evidence,
uh,
often,
more often than than we would like to see,
uh,
find that the prosecution has failed
to disclose some important evidence,
uh,
to the defense.
Uh,
and as a result,
uh,
the argument is that the trial has not
been fair because the government has a
duty to turn over,
uh,
evidence that tends to show
the person is not guilty.
So that issue could be raised there.
Uh,
sometimes,
uh,
people learn of jury misconduct,
that the jurors may have done something
that they're not supposed to do.
So that issue could be raised there.
And that's not exclusive list.
But that's an example.
And then again,
depending on the state,
it will either go to the
state intermediate court
or it'll go to the state
supreme court.
And again,
the person can petition in the United
States Supreme Court for review.
Again,
very unlikely the Supreme
Court is going to review it.
Most of the time they're not.
But if there's a really important legal
issue there or an issue in which courts
are divided than the supreme
court may take the case.
Finally,
the last resort for someone sentenced to
death is to file a petition for writ of
Habeas Corpus in the United States
district court where they are,
uh,
this basically is a petition that says,
I the death row inmate,
uh,
suing the warden of the facility that's
holding that person and being held here
in violation of the constitution
of the United States.
The fact that the state law issues no
longer those could be litigated in state
court,
but not in federal court.
There has to be a federal
constitutional violation.
I am held in violation of the federal
constitution in that there was racial
discrimination in my jury selection and
violation of the 14th amendment to the
United States constitution.
That's a classic example of
a plane that might be made,
uh,
in the United States district court.
Uh,
that court decides the case.
let's say it rules adversely
to the death row inmate,
uh,
the person can then ask the,
well,
first,
ask the district court to allow him or
her to appeal to the court of Appeals.
They're not entitled to an appeal.
Uh,
the district court can
either say yes or no.
This issue is important enough
that it can be appealed.
A,
or if the district court says no,
the person can go to the court of appeals
and make your argument a second time,
uh,
that this is an important issue.
Uh,
but very often that court will say no.
And so that's going to pretty much an end.
Of course,
the person will petition in the United
States Supreme Court for review,
but failing that,
that person is probably
going to be executed and
probably executed pretty soon.
Uh,
Texas is executed far more
people than any other state.
And one of the reasons,
um,
there was a lot of reasons,
but one is at once he's case
come to federal district court,
they're usually denied
a certificate of appeal.
Ability to the court of appeals is denied.
Uh,
so once this court rules,
uh,
there's nothing left between that
person and the execution chamber.
So a habeas corpus used to be a way in
which a number of capital cases were
reviewed and sometimes
set aside the difference.
Life,
tenure judges,
these judges are appointed
by the president,
confirmed by the Senate.
They serve for life.
Not to say there's not some
politics both in getting appointed.
And not to say that they're not some
federal judges who are ambitious to go on
to other places,
but at the same time there's
a lot more independence.
Uh,
when you have life tenure,
a judge in the state court
who makes a decision,
either a trial judge or a,
an appellate judge,
uh,
maybe signing his or her political death
warrant if they grant relief in a death
penalty case.
Uh,
not so for a federal judge,
uh,
and at one time the federal courts,
we're,
we're pretty vigorous and
enforcing the constitution,
uh,
Congress passed and President
Clinton signed into law a,
an act which we'll talk about,
which greatly restricts the power now
of the federal courts to review these
cases.
So that gives you an overview of just
when we're talking about these cases,
you'll have some sense of where they are.
We'll look at cases,
decided by state supreme courts will look
at cases decided by federal courts of
appeal.
So you'll know how that got there.
Uh,
and of course,
we'll look at a lot of United
States supreme court opinions.
Uh,
so I hope this gives you some sense of
where we are in the process as we look at
those cases.
And we'll also look at,
uh,
examples from trial courts as well,
including some transcripts of
jury selection and so forth.
So that's the roadmap
of where we're going.
And we'll next take up,
uh,
the historical sort of a backdrop,
leading,
uh,
to where we are today,
where the death point
of the United States.
Okay.